moi jean louis keumayou merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
arte france sénégal a pendant longtemps
été épargnée par les différentes vagues
désormais dakar subi de plein fouet
cette troisième comment expliquer ce
revirement
c'est que nous sommes dans un cas de
figure où le sénégal n'est pas le seul
pays qui est concerné par cette vague la
tunisie par exemple subi la même chose
actuellement l'afrique du sud a subi
cela également c'est qu'on a un problème
qui est celui sur le continent africain
de la pandémie naturellement mais aussi
des systèmes de santé qui n'ont pas
toujours été très performant on l'a vu
également avec la crise d'ebola avant la
cuisse de de covile 19 que les systèmes
de santé n'était pas prêt au fer face à
ce type de menaces nouvelles et donc
cela ne fait que mettre en évidence les
déficiences du système de santé des pays
africains le sénégal en fait partie
malheureusement fort justement le
système de santé sénégalais il refusant
les hôpitaux des patients que font les
malades ou vont-ils comment sont ils
pris en charge après avoir été refusé
je crois qu'ils ont plusieurs solutions
qui ne sont pas toujours conseillé la
première étant d'aller voir les crêtes
du praticien qui se débrouille avec les
plantes naturelles médicinales ou
répondre à ce genre de situation les
autres restent chez eux parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas aller dans un autre hôpital
ou même avoir la force d'aller chez les
tradipraticiens et donc ils sont dans la
nature personne ne les prend en charge
sont des personnes qui nous rentrerons
dans aucune statistique officielle et
qui continueront de souffrir de la
maladie voire de la transmettre à
d'autres personnes
mais comment réagissait sénégalais
ils sont en colère vis-à-vis de ça non
ils sont en colère mais dans le même
temps il faut avoir les moyens de sa
politique certains essaieront
probablement de se soigner d'autres de
droite earth ou plus à l'état mais
savent que l'état ne donnera que ce dont
il dispose
s'il n'a pas assez de doses de vaccins
pour immuniser pour arriver à cette
immunité collective qui est du v par la
plupart des pays il ne pourra pas faire
autrement
si par peur les gens commencent à
demander le sénégal a choisi par exemple
de devenir un hub afin de pouvoir
produire une partie des vaccins qui
seraient utilisés au sénégal voire au
delà dans l'ensemble des pays africains
c'est une démarche qui est loi parce que
cela permettra au pays de gagner un peu
en terme de souveraineté sur la gestion
des médicaments des doses de vaccins qui
seront utilisés mais tant qu elle notant
que le pays n'aura pas atteint cette
capacité de production propre et surtout
avec les peurs liées au fait que les
populations ne veulent pas toujours être
vaccinés
ça restera un combat très inégale et
dans lequel l'issue est incertaine et
dans sa globalité la population
sénégalaise à l'est pour aller contre le
vaccin pour l'instant et une grande rien
grand doute un peu comme en france et
dans certains pays européens
les gens ne sont pas convaincus que ce
vaccin soit pour l'instant la solution
il attend de remèdes qui puisse les
guérir prévenir c'est quand le mal n'est
pas encore là aujourd'hui lommel et là
il faut les trouver une solution et les
gens ont l'impression que la seule
réponse aujourd'hui qui est proposé et
le vaccin offre eu cette réponse n'est
pas toujours fiable et que par le passé
il ya eu de nombreux essais de vaccins
qui ont été pratiqués sur le continent
africain sans aucun contrôle et dans sa
vie en rajouter à la peur des gens je
cite également cette volonté de la
france et de l'union européenne qui
avait été de ne pas reconnaître les
vaccins du lot au pacs qu'ils sont au
dessus de lit dans les pays africains et
qui ne donnait pas droit aux mêmes à la
même possibilité de voyage pour ces
personnes qui avaient été vaccinées en
afrique et qu'il n'avait pas utilisé les
deux européennes pour le faire donc il
ya tout ce faisceau d'éléments qui
poussent les gens à être dans une forme
de scepticisme quant aux vaccins qui
sont utilisés dans leur pays
on l'a vu sur le sujet 1 sur la fin du
sujet plus précisément de françois
tessier beach ya eu plusieurs émeutes
ans au sénégal notamment pour réclamer
la fin du couvre-feu début juin en mars
et eu aussi des heurts qui ont éclaté
après les accusations de viol contre
l'opposant politique ousman sonko au vu
de la situation actuelle à dakar est ce
que le pays peut imploser de nouveau oui
tout peut arriver et surtout que nous
avons deux échéances importantes qui
attendent les autorités la première
c'est la rentrée scolaire qui aura lieu
sous peu et puis surtout le grand magal
qui est la fête religieuse de la confé
confrérie des mourides au sénégal ça se
passe donc à touba ce soit ces grands
événements là qui probablement doivent
donner des sueurs froides aux autorités
sénégalaises par rapport aux
possibilités de contagion et donc de
diffusion de masse de djokovic 19 dans
la société sénégalaise merci oui
camaïeu d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
du club de l'information africaine où
c'est justement en afrique autant bourse
comme on aime